eu leaders have described the shooting
of a prominent dutch crime journalist as
an attack on our values this man peda de
frise
was gunned down in amsterdam on tuesday
and remains in hospital in a serious
condition
authorities are investigating possible
links to his reporting
and his role in a court case against a
major criminal gang
described by police as a well-oiled
killing machine
a day after one of the netherlands most
famous journalists was gunned down
well-wishers gather on the street where
he was shot
witnesses say peter dufrese was shot
five times including once in the head
an incomprehensible crime for many here
shocking it's really shocking news what
happened to peter dufrese
it was really not expected even if a lot
of people did think he was doing
something dangerous
but it should never happen defrees had
just finished an interview on dutch tv
when he was attacked
the 64-year-old journalist rose to
prominence for his crime reporting
and as an advocate for survivors of
violent crimes
activities police long feared would make
him a target for reprisals
dutch authorities describe his attempted
murder as an attack on the country's
freedom of the press
and democracy and an attempt to snuff
out one of the country's leading voices
peter erdrich is franz alamal pedro
dufrese is a national hero for all of us
an uncommonly brave journalist tireless
in his search for justice
fully independent and free of spirit
dafrise is currently in serious
condition at this hospital
dutch police have arrested three men in
connection with the attack
including the suspected shooter so far
no motive has been identified
dw's max sunday is in amsterdam
following the story for us he's actually
in the street where mr freeze
was gunned down max let's start with
peter defley's condition what have you
heard
right nicole there is very little
information coming out of the hospital
where pita difference is being treated
at the moment also
due to security reasons but what we do
know is also
as we heard in the report that
eyewitnesses um
saw him being attacked by uh by by the
alleged gunman and he was shot with
up to five times also struck in the head
so we have reason to believe that he has
very very uh serious injuries and
is in a very serious condition and also
the mayor of amsterdam
we also just heard uh said in her first
uh first
public appearance first time talking to
the press about this that he is
in the hospital right now fighting for
his life
what do we know about the motives
well peter de frise is one of the most
popular journalists here in the
netherlands and he is by no doubt
the crime journalist has been working on
high-profile crime cases
for the past four decades and has been
shining a light on the
the dutch underworld so to say so he has
also been uh
been making a lot of enemies he's been
gaining a huge
audience but also making a lot of any
enemies and make and putting himself
into a lot of danger he has in the past
received death threats
and also has been under police
protection
before but apart from this we only know
what kind of environment he's navigating
right now
but all the the the evidence is uh
circumstantial at the moment it's not
yet clear uh what exactly the
circumstances of this attack were
there's been an outpouring of sympathy
after the attack what have reactions in
amsterdam
been to his being gunned down
that's right i mean as you can see
behind me there's a there's a
um a little a little site here this is
the site where he actually was gunned
down
almost 24 hours ago um through the
course of the day
a lot of people showed up just to to pay
their respects uh to
to uh to lay down some flowers um um
which is uh quite uh quite quite
something if you imagine that he's
he's this would that is he's been
injured but he has
he has not passed so he's in critical
condition in in the hospital yet and
still
uh he has a lot of followers coming here
um
in in support um and also uh look we had
international leaders also dutch leaders
um speaking about this calling this an
attack labeling this an attack on the on
the press
uh dutch prime minister mark ruta said
uh peter de fries was a
this was attack on a brave journalist
and also an attack on press freedom
itself
max sunday in amsterdam thank you very
much